maurice tupan bonjour bonjour bienvenue
dans la matinale de rtl france on le
disait d'études des tirs a entendu hier
à proximité du palais du gouvernement
situation confuse dans le pays qu'est ce
que l'on sait ce matin de la situation
sur place
alors pour le moment pas encore
d'informations qui a fuité meyer le
président de la république a fait un
point de presse pour informer que la
situation est sous contrôle après
l'attaqué du palais du gouvernement par
des assaillants a mis à part moi c'était
une tentative de coup d'état mais
jusqu'à présent on n'a pas encore
l'identité des auteurs mais aussi les
motivations réelles des
effectivement ce qu'il ya des
témoignages qui ont présenté ces hommes
comme des militaires d'autres comme des
civils on a une idée tout de même deux
qui pourraient être ses assaillants
difficile à dire à ce stade mais il faut
rappeler que ce cette attaque de coup
d'état intervient dans un contexte
politique et socio économie très tendue
ambitieux en guinée bissau il ya des
tensions entre le président de la
république et ses principales alliées
qui l'ont soutenu le les élections
présidentielles de 2010 neuf mais aussi
une situation économique caractérisée
pas des grèves de la fonction publique
qui complique tout petit peu les
conditions de vie des populations du de
la démission et ses tentatives de coups
d'état et aussi à inscrire
dans la trajectoire politique de ce pays
qui est catalysée par au moins quatre
coups d'état qu'est une issue des
assassinats politiques et dizaine de
tentatives de coups d'état
le président parlait de sa lutte contre
la corruption contre le narcotrafic on
peut faire un lien avec l'attak d'hier
alors ces véhicules à la lutte contre la
corruption et le trafic de drogue a eu
un impact négatif dans l'eau passait
dans la stabilité du pays
encore une fois difficile à dire s'il ya
ces allées lien direct entre cette
volonté du président de la bulle est de
mettre fin au trafic de dogue en
guinée-bissau et de lutter contre la
corruption mais il faut dire que
l'instabilité politique les que
l'entente guinée-bissau résulte non
seulement des tensions entre les acteurs
politiques mais aussi des failles de
l'architecte et institutionnelles du du
pays qui créent souvent des tanches on
rate le premier ministre le président de
la république l assemblée nationale s
étant sont souvent été à l'origine de
l'instabilité institutionnelle mais
aussi le sapin coup d'état dans le pays
sont ces failles précisément maurice
schumann alors dans la constitution de
la guinée-bissau vous savez que c'est
l'un des ratés en amphi de l'ess a
adopté un système présidentiel qui crée
un certain nombre d' équilibre entre de
partage du pouvoir entre le président et
le premier ministre mais il ya des
articles de la constitution qui ne sont
pas encore claires et qui nécessitent
d'être clarifiés c'est pourquoi la
cedeao
après le coup d'état de 2012 avait
proposé aux actes bissau guinée de
modifier la constitution
afin de clarifier ces dispositions
contractuelles qui crée souvent des
tensions alors on peut citer l'article
et qui dit que le président de la
république nomme le premier ministre
après avoir consulté le particulier qui
a gagné les élections et on voit que en
2015 ce n'était pas le cas ça crée les
temps chauds et bloquer les institutions
du pays pendant presque quatre ans et
l'a aussi rappelé les champs de
valhall malgré la victoire du psg c'est
aux élections législatives s'étaient pas
au premier ministre désigné par le parti
qui a gagné les élections mais ne met
pas le président de la république qui a
été élu comme premier ministre ce sont
des dispositions contractuelles qu'il
faut clarifier enfin le d'éviter ces
tensions entre les différentes
personnalités du pays et peut-être
prévenir les coups d'état alors on a
entendu un l'onu condamné ce coup d'état
en guinée bissao regretté également la
multiplication des coups d'état
récemment sur le continent africain
néanmoins est ce qu'on peut faire une
comparaison entre ce qui s'est passé
hier en guinée-bissau et ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui au burkina faso au mali par
exemple
c'est vrai que la fée de rennes prenait
ces temps-ci habile et les moments
difficiles avec des coups d'état dans un
certain nombre de pays dont le mali et
la guinée bissao mais je
la comparaison avec la guinée-bissau
pour moi ne le tiens pas passer de la
guinée-bissau à 1 3 ils seraient pas
politiques comme aux particuliers c'est
le seul pays de la région avoir eu son
indépendance par à une lutte une lutte
armée dans le contexte actuel sur le
plan sécuritaire contrairement aux au
mali au burkina la guinée-bissau n'en
prenaient pas anna régis pas de présent
de groupes extrémistes violents dont
dans son dans son territoire qui ont
dans une certaine mesure
favoriser les coups d'état ou mali en
guinée bissau mais encore une fois
l'instabilité
en guinée que ça est plutôt lié au col
et le politique mais aussi aux
défaillances de l'affecter
institutionnels et si on fait au fond
une lecture a poussé de ce qui se passe
actuellement dans ce pays ont noté les
tensions politiques entre les athées ou
politique mais aussi une volonté du du
président de la république d'avoir un
contrôle assez
fort sur les institutions de la
république ce qui ne correspond pas est
ce un politique au système de
gouvernance de la guinée-bissau qui
régime précisé me présidentielle qui ne
contrairement aux autres pays de la
région qui ont adopté un régime
présidentiel mais après les événements
d'hier à quoi s'attendre dans les
prochains jours est ce que on peut
s'attendre à une crise politique encore
plus importante
alors la lagune émission n'est pas à
l'abri d'une d'une crise politique il
faut il faut s'attendre après les
enquêtes liées à cet incident peut-être
aller de mesures fortes du président de
la république
qui viseront à neutraliser certains
éléments au sein de l'armée ou au sein
de
la scène politique à tentative qui
pourrait
créer accentué les tensions actuelles
mais aussi déboucher éventuellement sur
une instabilité politique donc pour moi
actuellement la guinée bissau et dans un
dans son cycle
qui pourrait
renouer le pays avec l'instabilité
politique merci beaucoup maurice tupan
pour votre éclairage ce matin sur rtl
france depuis dakar au sénégal je le
rappelle vous êtes directeur de
recherche à l'institut de sécurité du
sel